Maybe you want it you want you want some mall ambiance?
I got some.
I don't know if that'll get like copyrighted.
It's straight off YouTube.
YouTube hates me.
Hold on.
I'll show you what I what I like the most about YouTube.
The mall ambiance.
Please do.
We're live by the way.
Hello.
We got this.
She be caught in scuff that that is that's me.
I'm me.
I'm me a girl.
Oh my god.
I can hear myself.
Oh god.
Damn.
I hate when I do that.
Hello everybody.
My name is she be caught in bum.
And today we are joined by the lovely trinket trinket.
Why don't you go ahead and introduce yourself.
Why hello harem.
I'm trinket.
I'm your dog in law.
Or I guess your step dog depending on how you want to view me.
And I'm here to hang out with madam chibi today.
And we're going to see what Pokemon are smashable and what are passable.
Heck yeah we are.
Me and trinket go way back.
We met back in Hollywood as a trinket is a amazing actress.
It was it was an amazing time back then you know.
Early.
Thank you.
I miss you so much.
It's literally been years since I've seen you last.
I know.
I heard that you had gotten an office job girlfriend.
And I blew it off like they weren't paying me enough at this office job.
So I took this gig being a being a madam.
I mean a hotel manager.
And yeah I just like to broadcast my what I'm what I'm up to.
Lucky.
I'm still in that I'm still in that really weird phase where I'm looking for that perfect
role.
Are we all are we all still searching for that one perfect role.
Absolutely.
But trinkets information is in my description.
If you want to go check her out please do.
If you don't I will fight.
Thank you all.
I'm currently trying to add my background music.
I feel like I should drink for this.
I picked up vodka soda and a sangria.
Oh OK.
I didn't know.
I didn't know if you'd want it that.
So I haven't opened either one yet.
Okay.
Damn.
I might have to find something to drink.
I saw like a bottle of Tito's next to me but I don't want to freaking die.
Tito's is like that's.
Oh I know what that is at vodka.
Yeah Tito's vodka.
Yeah.
I do like mixing that with stuff.
Yes.
It's a good.
I don't have anything to mix it with.
I would have to just drink it straight.
Oh no.
That's like drinking tequila straight.
Yeah.
It was I did that the other day as you know doing bunny garden and I almost died.
Of course.
Let me I'm going to put a little thing.
I'm going to get a read like donuts and stuff and super chats at the end just so we can
be a little focused and not ruin the flow of such things.
Okay.
Of course.
I'm going to crack this bad boy open.
Ooh.
I would have I would have put it closer but I figure I'll leave I'll leave that to you.
The asthma to me.
I'm accidentally poor Bulbasaur around.
I was like so before this out like Tom and I was like cleaning my house and I was so
into like the music I was listening to and then I really had to pee and then it turned
into something else and so that's why I'm a little late.
Yeah.
She was telling me about that.
What song are you listening to that really got you grooving probably.
Probably.
I was feeling a little funky by the end because I was listening to the weekend out of time
but the Katronata remix and it's like very like 70s funky.
So pretty pretty good.
I like that a lot.
Actually I've been listening to a lot of Chaperon.
Oh, I need to start listening to her.
I heard she's been popping off.
I like her tone her sound.
It sounds very retro but new.
Yeah, I feel I kind of like the old retro-y sounds like I feel like the 70s 70 core pop
music is really catchy and I'm just like I just want to slowly groove and shake my butt
and I'm just like I know I want to insert it into my veins and just see the colors of
like it's vaporwave everywhere.
Like a drug.
That would actually be you know pretty funky.
I feel like that's just like mushrooms or LSD.
Man, if only, if only.
Oh, I may look a little bit different to some of you.
YouTube has come for my throat.
So I have to wear this cover up and I think it's pretty good.
It's literally just a standard YouTube studio asset.
It's a Lucy.
Yeah.
And Astrodia was just like they're really, they're really shitting on you right now.
And I'm like, okay, I'll cover myself up.
So that's why you'll see like alternative thumbnails that I've been editing.
And that I'm hiding my boob crack.
So, but yeah.
You know what you could get eventually, right?
What?
You could just get a button up shirt and just have it pop a button.
I'm kind of hoping for that.
I know my manager team is talking to our rigor and artists and asked if they could like to
button my shirt, but they have to do a whole new layer because the shirt is like not separated
to the jacket.
So it's like, we'll probably have to redo my whole top half.
Like I have a base though.
So it's like, it shouldn't be too hard, but it's extra work.
I also want to be able to toggle off and on my ropes because I look like a dominatrix 24 seven,
which is like, you know, I do have my off days.
I'm not, I'm not, I got to work.
Not always pleasure, but you know, it's fun to mix both.
Thank you for the rage, Johnny.
Hello.
Hello, I was just talking about you.
Do you like my cover up?
Hello, Mrs. Shibby's mom.
Hi.
I feel this feels like I'm having a friend over for like a play date.
And then Johnny's like check poking her head into the room like, how are you guys doing?
And we're just like making our dolls like make out or something.
Can I get Johnny snacks?
We are the snacks.
We are the snack.
You look, you look so fine today.
Can we just talk about this?
My uncle Minky really cooked an outfit.
Yeah.
Like this, uh, I can't stop staring at the tummy.
It's sex.
Oh, it reminds me of a certain someone.
I just can't put my finger on it.
But you know, it's an homage to like an old friend of mine.
Yeah.
I think it's really gorgeous.
Very like slave Leia-esque.
May she rest in piss wherever she is.
I know.
She'd definitely be rested in piss.
I, I, I, I 100% believe that.
Um, Shibby with an naval piercing.
When that actually be kind of cute.
I do like yours.
Trinket yours.
You're just pretty nice.
Thank you.
Usually it's a bone, but like, you know, diamonds are girls friends.
That's right.
That's true.
Oh, so well with your hair, like all the, all the, all the trinkets in your hair.
That's cause I'm a star, baby.
She's a star.
See her name up at lights.
Um, can you tell us about some of the work that you've done as a star trinket?
Oh man.
I have taken a group on walkies.
Oh.
And I have done monologue readings for multiple productions.
I haven't landed a lead yet, but I'm hoping, I'm hoping fingers crossed.
You know, I bet you'll get a lead soon.
100%.
Oh, absolutely.
And I don't mean the leash that I usually carry, but you know.
Oh, I have a hold on.
I think I, I think I have a leash on me.
Oh, no, that's not the leash.
That's all right.
There it is.
I got it.
So, oh, maybe I should take my, like, you have to teach me about like walkies and stuff.
I haven't taken them for walkies.
I usually just sit in their cage, um, my harem.
So you got, you got it.
You got to let them stretch their legs sometimes.
That's a good point.
Oh, I've been a bad madam.
I'll have to take them for walkies.
Maybe next time.
Oh, they'll love it.
Or maybe we can take them together at the, towards the end of this.
Cause it looks like they're into either walkies or steppies.
Yeah.
Like maybe we can walkies and steppies.
I can, you know, we'll split them into two groups and divide and conquer.
Four feet for the price of two.
That's, hey, that's pretty good.
That's a deal.
You haven't been neglected.
You haven't been neglected shop.
I feed you.
You have a nice crate.
I leave the lights on for you when I leave my house.
You're fine.
That's so kind of you, especially in this economy.
Yeah.
That light bill.
Yeah, exactly.
And I have air conditioning.
So you're not dying, you know, it's hot.
It was like 95 today in my area.
Oh, that's not so bad.
You guys are probably in a brisk 75 degree house.
Actually, according to my thermostat, it is a 70 a nice cool 70.
And then I, and then they can hang with my cat sometimes.
So.
Me and my fans air conditioning doesn't get down that low.
I, I can't even change it.
Like it like, uh, I don't know if it's like my landlords like determine for the entire
thing, but it's like locked and I, I can't change it.
I can only make it go cold or hot or turn it off.
It's 72 cold.
Oh, why is she be censored?
Oh, the other is trinket.
Get it right.
That's because I don't have the same assets as madam shabby.
Yeah.
Smaller.
Um, just like I see an Emmy, uh, the AI for YouTube does not pick up, uh, whoa chests.
So trinkets fine.
Trinket's like full Tom, she's good.
Yeah.
Tommy is totally allowed.
And then like, hold on.
Let me show off.
Like I kind of have you a little bit down, but like, look at her.
She's like, look how cute she is.
The little tail.
Wait, say something so you light up.
I am trinket.
Hi.
You know, I, for the first time you showed me this, I glanced for a second because
I thought you had a, a razor on the headdress.
And I was like, that's hardcore.
Man, I wish.
Wish a, wish a bitch would.
She will cut a bitch.
Do not fuck with her, everybody.
She will cut you.
I will cry.
One of us will.
I will.
Yeah.
I'll watch.
I'll watch you guys.
Am I cut?
Wait, hold on.
If she, you're doing the cutting on the bitches and I'm watching, does that make me a cook?
Am I sitting in the.
No, no, you would never sit in the cut chair.
You would be front and center.
Okay.
Yes.
I'll be, I'll be like directing.
I'll feel, I feel better about that.
Yeah.
Everybody's got to have a manager.
Exactly.
I take direction.
Well, do you now?
Of course.
I will, I won't, I'm not going to test that.
I'm just going to believe you just so we can keep this YouTube TOS friendly.
Oh, okay.
So do you want to, do you want to get into this?
Of course.
Let's start with this plant.
Okay.
This plant.
I, if I recall, I think the person you hung out with before that you kind of modeled your
character wherever she is.
Didn't you guys do like, like baby or like eat or Rob as well as smash or pass?
Was that, was that a thing?
Yeah.
We did, we did include others because some of them you can't smash because like clearly
they're babies.
Yeah.
But some of them do look delectable.
Like you could just, you could just eat them.
Like this one looks like a straight up onion.
Yeah.
I would probably eat this one, but I wouldn't smash it.
I would, I would eat it.
100% would consume this, this little, this little cabbage onion.
I would let him live.
He can, he can, he can just go on about his way.
Okay.
All right.
Understandable.
Um, which so, are you also a pass?
I'm going to pass.
You're going to pass.
Okay.
I guess I'm just, I'm hand-able lecturing everything.
Although not that I'm a, all the sort, but.
Well, to be fair, I don't, I don't like vegetables.
So.
Oh, I'm a, I'm a huge vegetable fan.
Oh, well you are, you are a rabbit, my dear.
That's a good point.
I didn't notice.
Um, I'm going to pass an Ivy store.
I feel like I would get poison Ivy if I tried to eat it.
So.
He's too cute.
His fangs are too cute.
That's a pass for me.
Yeah.
That's a pass.
I just got scared by my own, um, slipper.
I thought, oh my God, I thought something was touching my foot.
And I'm like, wait, this isn't one of the cats.
And I just freaked out a little bit.
Okay.
Anyways, moving on.
Um.
Can I say something about Venusaur?
Go off.
Say, say your truth.
I feel like he's the fat, ugly bastard of more like Pokemon.
Oh my God.
You're right.
He is.
Holy crap.
But like he would crush you if he got on top.
Oh yeah.
That would be, that would be pretty tough.
Getting mounted by that thing.
I'm good.
Again, I think I'd like contract some sort of allergy.
So.
Get some pollen in your eye.
Yeah.
Start sneezing.
I just don't even want to go through that.
I don't, I don't want to pollinate with this, this Venusaur.
And then there's the, the mega, which is a cuter version.
Yeah.
He's got some height to him.
But he's gonna be as heavy as hell.
Yeah.
I wish they like gave information about their like heights and weights.
That would be, that'd be pretty good.
This is terrifying.
The, the Gigantamax one.
I'm, I'm, you know, I'm slightly enticed by the, the little vines, but I'm going to
say no to words vine whip.
I'm, I'm looking at his face and he's just looking like, you know.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm going to get taken advantage of.
Okay.
I'm going to say this right now.
Should I put a disclaimer in my chat?
We are going to say some very out of pocket things.
So if you are a fan of two cute girls, uh, talking about smashing, eating, robbing
or passing on Pokemon, um, then I don't, I don't.
I will say something about like the, the Venusaur mega.
I'm going to steal that flower off his head.
Oh, I don't care if I have to rip it off.
I'm going to take that.
That's, yeah.
Yeah.
He's, he's got a cute flower.
I'm going to pick it.
Oh wait.
Are you still on the last one?
No, I'm not.
I'm on Charmander.
Oh, okay.
You're a child.
Okay.
Let me get Charmander.
Oh, that's a baby.
So that's it.
That's it.
That's an eatable creature.
That is pure meat right there.
You're going to eat Charmander?
Yeah.
I bet it tastes like jerky, like spicy jerky.
The only problem is he'd probably be well done because he's always cooking.
That's a good point.
I like my, I like my meat kind of rare.
So it's a little bit pink.
I like it rare.
Yeah.
You know what?
No, I wouldn't eat him.
Just, just for the fact that he might be well done.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, maybe because he's younger, he wouldn't be, it's like, like a veal.
So make them might be a little bit more rare.
I don't know.
Like maybe if I could cut off the tail and like sample him, you think?
Yeah.
That would just kill the whole thing.
Hmm.
Yeah.
You might, you'd have to like eat the whole thing.
You can't just like, just eat the tail.
That's true.
And then like, there's the war that when his tail goes out, he dies.
Yeah.
But like, if you cut it off and it doesn't go out, he could probably stay alive.
Oh, that's it.
You know, there's a, like, has anybody experimented with that cut?
Just cutting off Charmander's tail.
So fucked.
I don't think Game Freaks made the cooking Pokemon yet.
Yeah.
I have seen like an animation of somebody like chop it up.
Oh, I got a tweet that I'm alive.
Thank you for the reminder.
Oh, I have to retweet when you tweet that you're alive.
I always forget to tweet that I'm alive.
Okay.
Let me just pass the hardest thing because you just want to go and hit the ground.
Run it.
I literally, I just, and I can't like schedule tweets either because how I am.
You can't put links and schedule tweets.
And you never know if you're going to want a gorilla.
Exactly.
Sometimes I want to stream earlier.
Sometimes I, you know, have to use the bathroom.
So I run a couple minutes behind, you know, if you like that sometimes.
Got to keep them on their toes.
Never let them get your next move.
Exactly.
So I'm on Charmillion.
I'm going to type up my tweet and you can chat about your opinion.
Okay.
So for me, I think I, I think this will be my first smash because he's got them big, strong
arms.
And plus like, if you were to sit on his head, you could write his head cause he's got the
appendage up there too.
You're not wrong.
Not an eye.
I'm partially swayed by that, but he kind of just looks like he wouldn't like, he just
like, not like hitting and quit it, but he'd like just, he would complete you.
Yeah.
He wouldn't call me.
He would complete.
And then like, he just roll over and be like, so did you come?
And I'm just like, I'm not really, he just has that expression.
Yeah.
He looks cocky.
Like ain't not the best thing.
Yeah.
But even then, like, even if he did finish, like you could get off on your own.
He's got extra bits that stay hard forever.
That's a good point.
I'm wondering where he puts like, where's, where would, where it's going to come from.
But you know what I mean?
I'm going to pass and you're going to smash, right?
Yeah, I'm going to, I'm going to smash.
I feel like I should have had a counter, but it's fine.
I think it does it at the bottom, doesn't it?
I don't know.
It does.
It'll, it'll, it'll put a green box around the ones that you say smashed to.
Oh, okay.
I just haven't smashed anything yet, so that makes sense.
But that might change with the next one.
That's a good point.
Cause we got Charizard.
I am smashing the dragon.
Thank you.
I mean, I mean, he's our first short king.
He's a short king?
I thought he's a dragon.
I know he's a dragon, but Charizard's like canonical height is very short.
Is it really?
I didn't know that.
You know, I don't, I don't.
He's five, he's five seven.
Charizard's only five seven?
Yeah, he's only five seven.
You know, I don't mind that cause that's like, that's literally just like an inch taller than me.
So we could be like eye to eye.
That's like perfect height.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Five seven eight that short.
People, people, you feel like it's for a dragon.
Calm down everybody for a dragon.
For a dragon.
It's kind of small.
It's kind of small for a dragon.
Just, yeah, just for a dragon.
Also, you guys could totally do it while airborne.
So yeah.
He's a total smash.
Yeah.
I'm, I'm, I'm smashing the dragon.
Um, Charizard's mega.
Those baby arms.
Yeah.
I don't like them.
I feel like I would get hurt by the little, the double wings.
Yeah.
Like, like slapping would be nice.
But like, I don't, I don't know.
It's not feeling that, you know.
And then like the spikes on top of his head is totally unusable now.
Yeah.
I can't do anything with that.
I think it's a, I think it's a pass.
Yeah.
For the Y.
However.
I'm kind of feeling Charizard mega X.
I just like the color palette a lot.
He's also got built-in handlebars that aren't his hip.
That's a good point.
Maybe he's into pegging.
Maybe he, you know, be pretty cool.
I'm going to, I'm going to smash.
I'm going to smash that.
Same.
Um, no, I, no, put him, put him out, put him out.
I would just be on fire and he would just sit on me and kill me.
So.
Yeah.
He's doing, he's doing too much.
He just seems like he's, he's just like, yeah.
He's just trying too much.
Like he's like compensating for something, you know.
Although I do like his womb tattoo.
His.
Wait.
He has a womb tattoo.
Oh my gosh.
He does notice that.
That's pretty, that's pretty cute.
Um, okay.
This is a baby.
That is a baby.
I, I can't eat it because it's too baby.
Yeah.
I like, I also, Squirtle has a soft spot in my heart because they were my starter.
And I, like, when I first played fire red and I named him Squirt, not understanding
the connotation.
Um, so I'm, I have to pass.
I would, I would lovingly cherish Squirtle.
Squirt could mean a lot of things though.
Like he's a small fry.
He's a little guy.
He gets a squirt.
Exactly.
That's why I call him Squirt.
And it's like, you know, I'm a kid.
So I'm not that like smart when it comes to naming things because it's fucking in his
name.
Of course.
Squirt has fainted.
He is a friend shaped little guy.
I love him.
And then when he was blast toys, he was called Squirt.
I mean, to be fair, you're not wrong.
That water pressure though.
Uh, let's, I'm just going to pass.
Um, war total.
Oh, that's a smash for me.
That's a smash for you.
Yeah.
Again, I've always liked the way that war total looks, especially his fluffy tail.
He does have a cute tail.
Very cute tail.
And like his, I always liked his little like ear wing things, whatever that is.
Um, I wouldn't smash him though.
He just looks like, again, like a shitty, annoying teenager that like, I would probably
have to teach to do things to, so that I could complete.
So I don't know.
I think he could, I think he could figure it out.
He's got that, he's got that ginky anime protagonist.
Let's need some goggles on him.
And he's like a Digimon protagonist.
That's, that's a good point.
That's a good point.
Um, I am going to pass.
So, and then you got Blastoise.
I'm going to smash Blastoise.
Uh, this one's hard.
Yeah.
He's very handsome though.
Like he's a barra handsome.
Yeah.
And then again, like I mentioned the water pressure and I don't, I think I would like the sensation
of those, his like little claws gripping me, you know.
Also, I bet he's just really smooth.
I like that expression.
He's like, you know, like, he knows what he's doing.
He knows his way around.
Yeah.
He's a veteran.
Uh, and this is like his weird brother.
Yeah.
No, he's right off.
Oh, good.
And I'm not going.
I'm not going.
And that's a tank.
Um, I'm good with the gig, the Gigantamax 22.
Yeah.
That's a no for me.
He's only five feet tall.
That's fine.
That's okay.
I don't mind a short king.
Yeah.
We established that with Charizard.
I like, you know, they, they, they, they try a little bit harder because they know they're
not as tall.
It's never really mattered to me how tall you are, but like, I get it can be a soft spot
for some dudes, you know.
Yeah.
Especially if it's not fair and you're wearing heels all the time.
I still don't know my height without my heels because I'm 168 centimeters with heels and
I don't know how tall my heels are.
So I have to ask my mom.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hmm.
This is a caterpillar.
Well, yeah, but he's got one of those mouths that look like those sectiony toys.
Is that a mouth?
Yeah.
Does that open?
I mean, I just kind of assumed that it was like a hole in his face, you know.
And, you know, I feel like he could crawl up in there and just like do his thing.
Yeah.
And then he just come right back out.
You know what?
Yeah.
I'll do it.
I'm, I'm, I'll try new things.
Yeah.
I mean, bondage fairies walk so we could run.
Exactly.
All right.
I'm going to smash.
Metapod.
Again.
Harden.
It's a given.
I'm sorry.
I'm smashing.
I'm smashing metapod.
It's testing your limit.
Exactly.
And then like, look at all those ridges and edges like, come on, he's ripped for your
pleasure.
Exactly.
That was so good.
Oh my God.
Um, that's a bug.
The other ones were bugs, but this is different.
It's a butterfly.
This one's a little too delicate.
You get those wings wet and it's over for you.
Yeah.
Like, what if I'm feeling extra, you know, spicy that day?
I make a mess.
Like what's, what's going to happen to butterfree?
What's going to happen?
That's what's going to happen.
It's going to disintegrate in my shoes.
The pH acid.
Jesus fuck.
That's a horrible image.
Uh, I don't care, but it just has bigger wings.
That doesn't really make a difference to me.
Um, beetle.
Okay.
So this, this, this one, I'm a little torn on because I want the same.
Yeah.
But on the other, like a horn.
I'm like, I'm like, oh, maybe if I'm feeling a little adventurous,
cause like reminds me of beads.
Um,
Like you could grind on it, maybe.
Yeah.
Can use that as a grinder.
Like his little, his little sections part.
You got to be brave.
I don't know.
I don't think I'm that brave.
Yeah.
I just feel like my cervix would just be destroyed.
If I try to sit on his head.
Uh, and I feel like I would struggle,
like I would probably just crush him.
If I tried to grind on him.
So I'm going to say pass just for our,
both of our safety.
You know.
Yeah.
I'm going to pass on this one.
Pass on Weedle.
Cocuna.
Same thing as Metapod though.
Going up my ass.
Expeditiously.
I mean, if you, if you turn them upside down,
he's got a flared base.
So I can see where you're coming from.
Yeah.
Exactly.
You understand me.
I see you and you're so valid.
Thank you.
Okay.
Smash B drill.
He's already got it built in and on display.
I know it's like pointier,
but there's like something like,
like Weedle and stuff,
but like, I don't know.
There's just something about B drill that just like draws me to him.
I don't know.
I don't like bees.
That's true.
Like what it, is it going to sting me?
He's going to be an asshole the whole time.
Like you're not threatening him,
but he's going to be like sting, sting, sting,
plays it, sting, sting, sting.
Yeah.
Or just like just kind of like buzzing around,
like just like kind of being pastry.
Yeah.
Actually I'm going to pass.
I'm going to pass.
Me too.
Reminder.
This is Markiplier's first smash.
That's right.
He did smash B drill.
Well, that's because it's black and yellow,
and though they're two sexy color combination.
They are.
B drill mega would kill me.
Like I like a little bit of pain.
There's five spikes on this bucket.
I know.
And like that could like, you know,
impale all points of me,
but like usually I'm the one dishing it out.
So I'm going to say pass.
I still don't like bees.
Okay.
Pidgey, this is a bird.
I'm not smashing a bird.
I'm going to eat this.
You're going to eat.
Yeah.
I'll eat the bird.
I'll eat.
Yeah.
Cause like all these birds have cloacas.
Well, the cloaca doesn't turn me off.
Right.
It's the fact that it's a bird.
I don't really,
I can't recall what a cloaca looks like.
So can it like come out of it?
The bird?
Like, or do they,
don't they just like put their butts together?
Right.
I think it's like a sort of suction cup sort of thing for some,
except for like ducks who have the corkscrew.
Yeah.
The corkscrew pee pee and the corkscrew vagina.
Oh, well it's like a maze vagina.
Like a, yeah.
Cause they have like other, other.
Yeah.
I remember reading about that for some odd reason.
I'm not,
I'm going to eat the bird.
So pass.
Yeah.
We're going to,
we're going to eat that bird.
See this is a good meal.
That's a good meal right there.
That's a,
that could feed a family of three.
The Pidgeotto.
Yeah.
But then you were like talking about suction.
So like now I'm debating whether or not I want to fuck the birds.
I'm a fan of suction.
I'm not going to though.
I'm going to,
I'm not even going to eat that because I just feel like,
like preparing this,
like processing this bird would just like be such an annoyance.
Yeah.
I mean,
I didn't say I would prep it.
I'd probably catch it and give it to some like Pokemon chef.
Oh,
that's a good point.
Okay.
Cause I can't cook.
I have to cook you a meal sometime then drink it.
I'm going to pass on the verb.
Me too.
And then same for Pidgeot,
it's just longer hair.
I don't,
she's getting that anime protagonist hair.
Yeah.
And the same thing with Pidgeot mega,
it's even more so anime protagonist hair.
It's just like,
it's like an honestly gorgeous bird.
I would pass.
I would spare its life.
I also wouldn't eat it.
So,
yeah,
I'd want to see him flying free.
Why is the bird five feet?
What the heck?
That's so weird.
Because you can ride him,
but not in that way.
Oh,
that's a good point.
You know,
I let him take me on a date so I could just like fly around on him.
That'd be fun.
Um,
ratatata,
ratatata.
Um,
that's a,
that's a rat.
Um,
I pet him.
Yeah.
I'd snuggle him.
Um,
I don't think we could have coitus.
However,
uh,
I would probably kill him.
So I'm going to say pass.
Yeah,
he's baby.
that's a baby would not hurt the baby.
Yeah.
That's a baby with a mustache.
What's that?
A baby with a mustache.
That's a baby with a job.
No,
thank you.
I just,
I just feel like he has like a really thick,
like,
a New York accent.
Like,
ah,
I need to get to my appointment.
Okay.
Get out of my way.
I'm walking.
Yeah.
I'm trying.
I'm going to be late.
I'm supposed to see my,
my grandmother after this for some spaghetti
at her family restaurant.
You know,
I've had a very masterful,
as a kid,
oh,
this is,
He does. He does. He does have that feel. He does. He just needs a hat.
He just needs a hat. Just like a little, like a fedora, bowler hat.
Um, pass.
My brother Tony says.
And if you don't pay up, we're gonna have problems now.
Okay, eradicate. Um, I'm kind of scared to eradicate.
I feel like it would bite my clothes.
I mean, I don't think I would let his face to be downstairs.
Is it the tail you maybe might use?
You know, I don't think I would. I don't think I'd use this rat at all.
I think it's just a straight up pass.
What if he's hungry and eating?
I thought they accidentally sent a smash.
You can click on it in the bottom.
Yeah, there you go.
Oh my God.
I don't know what we got so far.
The rats, the rats are just a.
Yeah, the rats. I'm good.
And we're back to another eating line.
I'm telling you.
Tony.
Yeah, I'm eating this. I'm eating this bird.
He looks delightfully.
So good.
Those legs, like I don't, like I've never had chicken feet before,
but those look like really tasty feet.
Oh, like you would eat those pickled.
Yeah, 100% are like fried up crispy.
Yeah, you can't lie.
Are you the big cheese rat?
Mr. Bombastic.
Mr. Love a lover.
Actually, I do. Yeah, he's pretty cool.
Oh, are you going to say I'm sorry?
I like the biggest rat.
Small rat hate.
Okay, I'm passing on Spiro.
Spiro looks like an asshole.
Again, I'm just scared of his beak.
I feel like I would be impaled.
So I'm good. I don't even want to eat it.
I just feel like it would be really not tasty meat.
Because it's so full of fear.
You know how like fear can spoil a meat.
Can fear spoil a meat or does it make it the most electable?
Wow.
Hmm. That's it. That's the question.
That's the question of the century.
But then again, I guess happy cows make for happier steaks.
So it can drill.
Okay, we also people are wanting us to take into consideration
their their move sets because this has drill pick.
No, I don't want to drill anywhere near my business.
Okay, I'm passing.
I don't I don't need a hole drilled up into my womb.
Drill pack my cervix.
Um, how can emotions change in me?
Emotions can change in me because when you are feeling certain emotions,
it releases different chemicals in your body.
So that can take change the flavor of the meat.
But yes, um, this is a baby.
But it's a yes.
We are fucking this baby.
Don't please don't.
Oh, God.
Um, yes, I'm going to smash.
That's because it literally is anal beads on its tail.
So sign me up.
See, I know.
And it's little tongue is mouth is cute.
Yeah, I can have always been cute.
And I think Jesse and James for that.
Underappreciated Pokemon always.
Uh, Arbok smash.
Oh, absolutely.
Also, I bet he's a really good coupler afterwards.
Oh, yeah, just like kind of just like, um, coil around you and you guys can just like
hang out.
I feel like you would give really good kisses.
I don't know that tongue.
Like I have his teeth, but like tongue, the end of that tail.
Yeah.
Also, you got to take into account that snakes have to.
Oh my God.
You're right.
Oh, smash.
Smash.
Pikachu.
Pika, Pika.
That's an E for me.
Uh, yeah, I'd eat Pikachu.
I would not smash them.
Uh, but I would eat them.
Uh, I feel like they would have like either like a Zesty.
Citrusy flavor or like it would pair well with that.
Like I feel like a Pino.
Um, Grigio.
Something right to pair with.
Yeah.
Uh, I would eat Pikachu.
Mm hmm.
Yeah.
Not into electric stimulation.
Yes.
But like we'll get to that.
Don't worry.
I just wouldn't, I wouldn't fuck this mouse.
This particular one now.
Yeah.
This electric mouse.
I'm gonna pass, but eat.
Uh, that's a fat boy.
I'm good.
Yeah.
But he'll crush me.
The original fat boy is back.
Oh.
Oh, fat Pikachu.
I don't, I don't mind a little bit of chub.
I don't mind a little bit of chub or chunk, but, um, I would eat this one still.
Uh, especially cause it's probably, it's maybe more flavor from the fat on the meat.
You know what?
You know what makes me laugh?
Mods are asleep.
Post path, fat Pikachu.
Yeah.
Tell me, are you like my only mod right now?
I'm just kidding.
Everybody's been pretty good.
I might.
Yeah.
They're probably just hiding.
They're just, you know, the marbling would be insane.
That's like a wagyu.
Uh, he's so full of happiness and delicious.
Yeah.
Oh, that would be a delectable meal.
Absolutely delicious.
You'd cook him like you would cook Korean barbecue.
Yes.
Um, what about Raichu though?
Oh, that's a smash for me.
Yeah.
Explain.
I need, I need the details.
Okay.
So when I was younger, I had them.
Right.
Oh, okay.
I was like, where is this going?
I guess, I just think Raichu is like the cooler cousin.
Or I guess the cool dad of Pikachu.
Okay.
He's got an extra chewy tail.
If you guys like one of the original like Raichu toys.
Oh, good point.
I also like to chew on stuff myself.
So I totally understand.
I'm literally like eating some applesauce and showing on the cap right now.
I wouldn't smash them though, but I wouldn't eat them.
Um, I don't know.
I just like to hang out.
Like shoot the shit Raichu, I think.
Understandable because he probably is really good at conversation.
He's a war vet, don't you know?
That's yeah.
Yeah.
He's been through a lot.
A lot of good stories.
Um, Raichu Alola.
God, I want to eat him.
I also, yeah, I would devour this thing.
I don't know.
I feel like it's like caramel toffee.
Like dessert.
With a little bit of vanilla.
Yeah.
Some whipped cream toast.
Or like some like some sort of cream filling.
And you know, I love me some cream filling.
Oh, absolutely.
Like a Boston cream donut.
Oh, yep.
I am devouring this one.
Yeah.
Uh, Sanchu.
That's a baby.
Yeah.
I love all of them.
They're just so cute.
I love their little eyes.
So pretty.
Oh, I have always liked them.
Yeah.
They're cute.
We'll pass.
It's a, it's a pass.
Uh, what about the Alolan one?
Looks like a little igloo.
This is a baby in a different color.
This is, this is, this is alternate ethnicity.
Baby.
Um, yeah.
We'll pass.
This one's from the Arctic.
It's fine.
I might eat this one.
Cause I feel like it would be like a vanilla,
like creamy popsicle.
So I'll eat it.
Or I might like bite the tail off.
Or like just come the tail.
Just give me a taste.
Like, like Sonic ice.
Like you could just pick the bricks off of him.
Yeah.
Exactly.
I got it.
It's going to be a pass for me.
Yeah.
A pass.
Sand slash.
Yeah.
I'm worried about them claws.
And everything looks sharp.
A lot of edges.
Uh, the horn on the head looks too sharp.
I don't think you could ride that.
No.
Yeah.
Unless he's like soft.
I can't really tell if he's like, can he like harden?
Can he like make himself softer?
Cause I don't want to, and again,
I don't want to hurt myself,
but I'm going to pass cause I don't know.
I'm going to pass too.
Uh, that's a popsicle.
Um.
You'd get stuck.
Yeah.
That's an, I like, I would definitely my tongue.
I can't even eat that.
Or he'd get stuck.
If you know.
Oh.
Because of the two differing temperatures.
Good point.
Ow.
Uh, yeah.
I'm going to say no.
Like an ice cube up there.
Oh.
If it was like a little bit of play,
like a little foreplay with it,
I'd be fine.
But like if it's up there,
I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm good.
I'm good.
It's the whole time.
It'd be the full time.
That's so cold.
Uh, what did I melt it?
Like I feel like my body heat would bring it down.
Or maybe I would just get fucking hyperthermia.
You probably get hyperthermia because I don't think he'd melt
the pill he's done.
You know?
Oh gosh.
Yeah.
I'm good.
I'd get wet, but not in the right ways.
Um.
Uh, dish it a little dish it a little baby.
I would pass.
I wouldn't even eat it.
Nah.
Same.
Also it's poison.
Yeah.
Just a little guy.
Just a little boy.
You know what I didn't realize what this was for the longest time?
I didn't realize that these were rabbits.
What?
These are rabbits?
They're rabbits.
Oh my God.
I literally thought they were like mice.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
What the frick?
I'm going to pass.
Um, Nidorina has some like bedroom eyes, but she's a little bit young
for me for this one.
So I'm going to pass.
I can only think of that hamburger biscuit animation from a long time ago.
Oh my God.
They are like really cute.
And like, every time I see her I think hamburger biscuit.
Is that, is that a smash for you then?
Yeah.
Nidorina is a smash for me.
Okay.
I'll smash Nidorina too.
We can, we can, we can visit Paris together with Nidorina.
Yeah, we can.
I feel it.
Uh, Nidorina queen?
Uh, she's a queen.
Of course that's a smash.
Uh, yeah.
She looks like she got some tickle bitties.
So I'm going to, I'll smash.
This is also, I can't believe, I am literally mind blown that I did it.
Fucking based off of rabbits.
I'm like actually frustrated.
I'm going to say no.
Because again, baby, baby rabbit.
So it's probably my distant relative.
Did you know I'm canonically related to every bunny character in pop culture?
Wow.
Yeah.
In some way shape or form.
Mm-hmm.
Very well connected.
Yeah.
I don't, it's just, it's a soft, it's a touchy subject for me, but, um, my mom, who is Jessica
rabbit may have cheated on Roger rabbit with bugs to make me, but I'm not sure.
I'm not sure.
It's just a rumor.
Honestly, I put that kind of just like that, that behind means moving on with my life,
you know, not going to linger on it.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
I guess I never knew.
I'm so sorry.
Yeah.
It's tough.
Um, but I'm going to say pass.
Yeah.
I'm going to say pass.
He's on all fours.
That's a pass for me.
He's up.
Look at all those little ridges.
I know.
Yeah.
Wait, why is he on all fours and the arena?
Is it?
Because a lady doesn't crawl.
That's a good say it louder for the people in the back.
A lady doesn't crawl.
I love that.
Unless she wants to.
Unless you ask politely.
Exactly.
So he's a, he is low key a pass for me.
Yeah.
I feel it gives me like jock vibes, like football player vibes.
But like a dick one, not like one of the nice sweet ones.
Oh, like one who would take you under the bleachers and like.
Yeah.
Call you again.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I'm good.
I'm eating this.
It looks so sweet.
It's, it's cotton candy.
I'm eating it.
Um, I'm trying to think about how he would copulate if we tried, but I can't.
So that's, I'm eating it.
If I can't fuck it, I'm eating it.
I mean, it would have metronome, you know, metronome might be worth it,
but you never know what you're going to get.
Yeah.
I'd eat, I'd eat this one before I smash it.
Okay.
I'm safe pass.
What about Clefable?
Oh, that's a horse of a different color because he's bigger or she's bigger.
I guess.
Yeah.
And she's throwing up gang signs.
I know.
Okay.
Does that mean she's for the streets though?
Like.
Yes.
She's for the streets.
She's straight from the moon.
Yeah.
I don't know if I want a girl from the streets.
She'd be, I'm from the streets.
Oh, no.
That's not what I meant.
She'd be, I'm from the streets.
Oh, no.
That's different.
It's different.
Um, I'd probably, you know, I'll let Clefable escape with her life.
I'm not going to eat them because I need to consider it for longer,
but I'll say pass for now.
You know what?
I'm going to say smash, but on the caveat that I can get a double team with Gengar
with them.
Ooh.
That's, I like that.
Then yes, it's a pass for me.
Okay.
It's a situational pass.
I understand that.
Um, bull picks.
Oh, that's a baby.
Yeah.
I'm sure you don't, but I just want to snuggle it.
Well, babe, I'm like, like the hair.
Like the, so.
That's a baby.
I can't, I can't smash that.
I can't eat it either.
It doesn't really look that tasty.
Just cute.
Um, however I would eat, it's a lonely cousin.
Oh hell yeah.
That is, that is that good.
It's no code.
Oh hot.
Just like a little bit of drizzle of your favorite syrup on that thing.
Eating.
That's going right in my mouth.
100%.
Um, smash, pass or four.
Eating.
So I'm going to pass nine tails.
Smash.
Oh God.
A nine tails.
All right.
Don't even discuss it further.
Uh, what about the Alolan version?
That is an extra pretty one.
Yeah.
I, yeah, I'm going to agree with this.
I feel like it would just be really sensual.
Also they're wispy because they're like park ghosts.
So like, yeah.
You know, I'm into it.
Maybe they have, you know, a little something, something that only ghosts can do.
Only ghost types can do.
Um, jigglypuff.
This is a piece of bubble gum.
I know.
Just like immediately it would like move to speak and I would just pick it up and
pop it in my mouth.
Um, so yeah, I'm going to pass and eat it.
I'm, I'm boring this jigglypuff.
I am chewing it like bubble gum and blowing.
Yep.
And it's a little, I bet, you know, I'd make it.
I would freeze it.
I'd freeze wiggly tough into one of those like SpongeBob popsicles because their
eyes look like gumballs.
And I would eat it like that.
That's, that's what I would do for wiggly tough.
Hmm.
I'd only want to chew on the hair.
I don't want to.
Hmm.
I'd only want to chew on the hair.
Yeah.
The rest is a pass.
Okay.
Understood.
You know, from a certain angle, his back foot looks like something else.
So I did have to do a double take.
Um.
Yeah.
I see what you're saying.
But no.
Yeah.
That's a foot.
And I mean, his foot could go up there, but that's more of like a threat of violence
at that point.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm just getting kicked in the crotch at that point.
Zubat.
That's a bat.
Yeah.
That's a straight up bat.
Um, I don't even know what you could do with that because his legs are really fucking
weird.
It's all mouth.
So maybe actually, maybe it's good of the, that the lingus of con.
I don't know.
You know.
No, not this one.
Not this one.
Honestly.
I feel like this one might start a second pandemic.
Okay.
I'm passing the fuck out of that.
I'm not even going to try to eat it.
I'm not saying with gold bat because you said that I'm just scared.
I just, I don't want to repeat on this.
Uh, although gold bat's mouth is so tantalizing, but there's actually, I don't see a tongue
in there.
So yeah, I'm going to, we're passing.
We're passing.
I feel like he had tongues in the past though, right?
Did he?
I don't know.
I'm Googling this.
Cause I feel like gold bat, gold bat had a tongue in the past.
I feel like you're right.
The same thing happened to me when I was looking for a character with a black lip in like Hannah
Barbera cartoons.
And I know that bitch had a black lip, but when I looked her up ain't nothing but red
lips.
And I'm like, I swear I have like a red or pinkish or like purplish tongue.
Oh my God.
Is this like Mandela effect right now?
I think we're in them.
I think we're, I think someone shifted the universe like again.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure I agree with that.
Cause I know this fucker had a tongue.
Yeah.
You're, you're right.
I'm going to, I'm going to pass though.
I like his little cat ears.
His ears are so fucking small.
It's like a little kitty cat with wing, wings for little hands.
Um, yeah, this is a pass.
Audish.
He's kind of useless.
Audish, I'm going to eat.
I know you don't like vegetables.
So I know you're, that's also a baby.
So you're probably going to pass that.
Yeah.
I'm going to pass.
He can stay in the little ground like a mandrake.
I'm chopping up Audish.
I'm sorry.
I'm going into a really nice salad.
Gloom.
I mean, it looks like somebody already beat us to it.
Oh my God.
I don't want sloppy seconds, man.
I don't want whatever that is leaking out of Loom's mouth from somebody else anywhere
near my business.
And I'd probably trip and it'd probably be a bad trip or something and not have a good
time from whatever things that would release spores.
Jesus.
Good.
I'm not even eating that.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
But it's already pre season.
So would you?
I mean, yeah, maybe.
Okay.
It's got berries on the top.
So it's like part fruit.
That's a good point.
Those are berries.
I forget.
I always think they're like pods, like seed pods of some sort.
So I try it at least once.
And if the flavor didn't agree with me, I'd, you know, I'd never again.
Understood.
My chat is freaking out.
I love it.
What about, what about Viola Plume?
This gentleman can, can pass on.
He can, he can leave.
Yeah, I'm good.
Uh, with the, the eyes, the expression, I'm kind of put off the head.
Like I, the flower, it looks like a suction, but I don't think it does that.
So are you reading chat?
Yeah.
Honestly, I feel like this Viola Plume is just tipping his flower, like my lady.
And that's so cool.
No.
It's a little cringe.
I'm going to say pass.
Also, he's kind of stinky.
Yeah.
Stinky, stinky little boy.
Uh, pat us.
I'm eating it because I love, I love shellfish.
Um, and literally my cat's food is going off.
Um, so you're going to hear some cat munching.
Um, but it literally comes with mushrooms to put on the side of the crab.
So I'm going to eat it.
Oh, to answer, to answer the question, I'm trinket right now.
Yeah.
This is trinket.
Nice.
Nice to meet you.
Um, Tomas, Tomas busy.
So we have trinket.
That's fine.
Maybe next time.
Yeah.
Um, so I'm going to pass.
What about you for the crab?
Um, I don't eat fish.
Mm-hmm.
So I'm going to say pass.
Okay.
But I would pet him.
Yeah.
I always like, like holding the little crabs, like hermit crabs.
Like I would never eat a hermit crab, but like this looks more like a regular crab,
but I would hold a hermit crab.
Anyways.
Parasect.
Does it, is it just me or does he look like he have a really big happy smile?
I was literally actually just thinking that and I couldn't tell if it was its mouth or
for it was like a section portion of the body.
And now I'm like really wondering that in its eyes are dead.
I just feel like it'll be brought in food.
So I'm not going to eat it.
Honestly, I just feel like he's about to open his big mouth Muppet style.
He's going to be like, hi-ho, parasite here.
Coming at you lie from smash or pass.
Well, why don't you smash me?
And I'm like, nope.
I mean, look how big my mushroom is.
I could plug you up real nice.
I don't know why he sounds so tiny like this.
I'm for the swies, queens, if you know what I mean.
It's dead.
The mushroom is a parasite.
Oh yeah.
That's right.
So it's really the mushroom puppeteering the crab.
So I'm good.
I don't want it.
I don't want to turn into that.
No, I'm good.
I don't know.
This is a left for dead situation.
Why did he turn into Sean Connery?
Hey, I'm Sean Connery.
The Muppet.
The Muppet Sean Connery.
The Venonette.
He's so fluffy.
I know.
If I try to eat that, I feel like I would just choke like a hairball.
So I'm good.
Very cute.
Wood pet.
Wood snuggle.
Yeah.
I'm going to pass on this one and not eat it.
He's just too cute.
Yeah.
This little guy.
I bet he's as delicate as a moth.
Yeah.
Oh, just like cradle them in their little hands.
Cute.
Cute moths.
You know, I never understood why he turned so ugly.
I know.
It's fucking bug eyes.
Why are you so ugly?
I'm staring at you.
I'm staring at you in my big eyes.
Yeah.
I'm not.
I feel like it would just crawl into me and lay eggs.
And not even like Caterpie would crawl in and hang out.
And that's fine.
It's already there.
But I'm off.
I'm good.
Yeah.
Caterpie's just cave exploring.
This creature would be trifling looking.
Yeah.
Like.
Like, could you not?
I feel like that's like a Carlton.
Not a Carlton.
Oracle voice.
Excuse me.
Why does everything sound the same for the voices of me?
Did I do that?
Excuse me, my sweet madam.
Would you mind if I laid my eggs in your beautiful crevasse?
Please.
Oh, please.
Won't you let me?
I'll let you ride my horn.
I don't even mind if you get my wings wet, mistress.
Yep.
That's literally, that's the voice.
I'm passing.
Diglet.
Smash.
Going up my ass.
I mean, I'm a front door girlie.
I'm, you know, I'm a front door girlie too, but like, I, like, I know a plug when I say
what.
I mean.
Yeah.
I'm, I'm, I'm riding that Diglet.
Of course.
Until the, uh, the mill tanks come home, you know, you know what I'm saying?
It even, it even has a button for the front, you know?
Oh yeah.
What's, what's Diglet's move set?
I forget.
Dig.
Super.
I mean, you could probably teach him tackle to it with your really desperate.
That's right.
He needs to breathe.
Don't worry about it.
He doesn't have to breathe where he's going.
I'm smashing.
Diglet.
Oh.
This is just not the day.
This one has built in birth control.
What the f***ing IUT.
Yeah.
I'll, I'll, I'll sit on this Diglet too.
This one's for sharing with the homies.
Like, um, you can ride one.
I can ride one and then we can get a friend to ride the other one.
Did we have any...
I don't think I sit in, sit in the cock dirt.
Cock dirt.
Are you okay?
F***ing cock dirt.
Oh.
Um, uh, or yeah.
Okay.
I'm, I'm smashing the trio.
Well, I just feel like you can't anymore with this one.
He really laid that lay so well.
I don't want to mess it up.
Just because of the hair.
I don't, I don't.
That's a pass.
I don't want to get it messy.
I don't want to snatch her, his or her wig or weave off.
He put down a whole paycheck for those three.
I'm not messing that up.
I'm not, I'm not messing that up.
No, not one bit.
Oh, accidentally moved my, I meant to move myself a little bit to the side.
Um, Meowth, this is a cat.
That's a cat.
I can't eat it.
I'm lighting the cat.
If I steal the gold, if the gold coin on its head is chocolate, then yes.
Honestly, I just steal the whole cat and make him do payday every day.
That's a good point.
So we are, we're, is this, is this our first Rob?
Yeah, we're, we're robbing this one.
We're robbing this one.
Okay.
We robbed this one.
We're going to take, we're taking the whole cat.
We're taking the whole cat.
We're robbing this cat.
We're stealing this cat.
Uh, uh, what about this long boy?
My interest.
Straight to jail.
Don't.
I thought you said straight to jail.
Straight to tail.
And I was, I'm like, what do you mean that tail?
I mean, what that tail do is like between me and the bedroom and that cat, but that's
not a, that's not a smash.
That's a smash and grab.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm stealing this whole cat.
That's not long.
Yeah.
We're stealing.
I feel like we could really shake some money out of him.
Like, I don't know.
Okay.
Perfect.
Uh, great googly moogly.
What the fuck is this thing?
That is a man.
I don't need a little Danny DeVito trash man.
Um, I'm good.
I'm good with Meowth Galar.
Where's it?
Galar.
How do you, how do you do that?
Where's it?
Galar.
How do you, how do you say the name?
I'm going to, I'm going to go like Galar, like a Galar.
Galar.
Somebody chat.
Tell me.
Hey, how do you, how do you pronounce?
You can like correct my pronunciation because you know, I'm, I'm shit at pronounce, pronouncing
things.
Man, he just wanted to give you a hug.
Gala.
It's Gala.
Galar.
Okay.
So he's a pirate.
Um, pass.
Oh, what about the Alolan Meowth?
Okay.
This one's pure sex.
I, I gotta agree that expression.
It's doing something to me.
She, she really cute.
She cute.
I think, and you know, I was debating whether or not if I should like bed her than rob her,
but I'm like, no, I feel like we'd have a good wine night stand.
I feel like she'd treat me to like dinner and like she'd pay, like I'd offer to pay
like split pay.
And then we'd like be like, oh, maybe split and it's just, you would just pay it.
Um,
She looks like she would be a sugar mommy.
Yeah.
I'll, I'll smash.
Me too.
Yeah.
Okay.
Ah, classic.
Classic Persian.
Cats of barbed penises.
I mean.
And I'm not averse to a little pain.
I mean, I'm gonna say smash because I've always liked Persian.
Same.
Like, they just have that really nice sleek look.
Yeah.
How do you know that?
Because I have cats.
Oh, great.
People are going to be like, she be fucks her cat.
No.
Stop that right now.
There's a difference between a Pokemon and a real animal.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Whoopie is my little baby boy.
And like, we've all, we've all read comic books.
Where there's like a handsome cat man.
No, I was thinking that's what you said.
She doesn't.
I mean, I mean, and Persians about as smooth as the cat returns Baron.
Oh, but I love Baron from the cat returns.
He was my first crush on an anime character.
That's because he's so charming.
All right.
I want to smash Persian.
Me too.
This is what sugar mommy turns into after the age of 60.
I'm okay.
I'm okay with this cougar.
I don't know.
I smash her.
You smash her?
Okay.
She's, she's not like, I smoke 10 packs a day.
Yeah.
She got the roastie voice.
She's like, Hey, sugar.
You want to have like a mattress full of bills for you.
Yeah.
Like you, like you don't know what she even does for her money because she just like lives
so oddly.
Like you'd think she's like, you're like, is she a drug dealer?
Like why is she like, how do you like, she's not like elegant.
No, but she does live in decadence.
Yeah.
That's 100% very often.
Oh yeah.
You don't see her for like months.
I know mama and she'll be like, I've been in Hawaii.
Don't worry about it all.
Here's buy yourself something nice.
Here you go.
And it's like, hands you like a cool hundred.
And you don't question it.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Um, I probably steal the jewel in her head, but I'm going to pass.
I'm a smash.
Okay.
Honestly, I understand.
I totally understand that decision.
Uh, side duck.
That's a duck.
Uh, he doesn't know what the duck he's doing.
So yeah, I'm, I'm, I don't, I don't feel like fucking a duck.
That's confused all the time.
He's, he's always got headaches.
I would feel sorry for him more than anything.
Yeah.
I just like, I don't know if I'm out of his misery.
Like duck is delicious.
Yeah.
I was debating whether or not to eat him.
I think I would.
Um, but I'm like, maybe, maybe if I let him, you know, bust a nut, like on my
feet or something, like maybe it would like relieve some of that headache.
Have you ever like, you know, rubbed one out and just like relieve a headache.
Oh yeah.
All the time.
Yeah.
Exactly.
So I feel like I wouldn't smash a duck.
I'd help him out.
Oh yeah.
Just like a quick pop to the back of the head and he's out of his misery, out of
the headache.
And then you, and then you have somebody cook them right up.
Yeah.
Okay.
Delicious.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to pass, but I like this plan.
Oh my God.
Oh gosh.
Taking.
Piki Psyduck.
I'm rubbing gold duck.
Oh, absolutely.
That gym is just tend to actually, uh, yeah.
I don't really see like the tails are a little bit tantalizing sometimes, but
I'm going to say no.
Yeah, like, I don't.
I've always wanted, like what the heck is gold ducks texture of their skin?
Like, are they like smooth?
smooth are they soft because like Psyduck looks a little like a little bit feathery but like Golda
looks slimy and early yeah like he's well moisturized but like he's still wet from the lotion feeling
yeah yeah i don't like that i'm i'm gonna pass no i don't like that but i would i would i would
pop them in the back of the head for that gym yeah it's a little one two well we can split
we'll split the uh the profits um manky this is a monkey he's probably got really good stamina
though true and i know you're a fan of monkeys of course so i'm gonna pass but are you gonna
smash manky manky spanky because like because like not only does he probably have the stamina
he can probably like get really up in them guts yeah yeah yeah i'm just like i'm just wondering
where he's packing it though you know like oh he's literally just ahead well i mean sometimes animals
have innies good point that's a good point it's retractable okay okay understand thank you guys
thank you for that input i'm gonna pass on manky though primate uh like look how strong he looks
i was gonna say smash because i feel like i would like the aggression um i need someone to match my
freak and i feel like primate would uh i feel like primate pulls hair yeah i feel like he chokes
really well but he like doesn't do it the wrong way he does it the right way yeah you don't smash
him smashes you yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna smash primate yeah same i like the little ears i do too
i've always liked his little ears yeah growlith okay but this is a puppy yeah i would i would just
keep it like as a pet or just like pet him or like when i see it on the street be like oh my god
can i pet your growlith and then the trainer like yeah and then i'd be like oh so cute yeah
yeah i'm not doing anything else with that however oh wait no i was i thought it was gonna be something
else i don't know what the fuck this is but i'm not eating it it looks like spicy though
he does look a little spicy he's from uh the the prequel game yeah yeah that's right honestly
he doesn't look as soft or as inviting as his as his uh as his descendant yeah he also has like
i can't tell if he only has two he only has two claws on the front well they all do wait i never
know stuff before why did i think they're all paws what the heck is wrong with me uh i'm gonna pass
same however arcanine is what i was gonna get to yes that's a smash that's a smash we are smashing
arcanine thank you yeah okay i'm not gonna i'm not elaborating however i'm not gonna smash its
the creepy uncle arc i don't know i'd smash the creepy uncle he just looks like he smokes a lot
and reeks of cigarettes okay but i like the smell of cigarette smoke okay you know to each
their own i might i might watch that one i might take my turn um and watch and send the the cock dirt
and then watch that take place just i mean i don't i don't think there's anything wrong but i do it
because like as you know i'm i'm a dog that's true you are a dog i'm a bunny so i might get a little
broken but it is one of this sometimes i get mistaken for a horse and it's fine though i mean
because we don't have to elaborate on what he's packing yeah uh although i am thinking about it
i kind of want to describe it for chat but i'm not gonna say it oh god i kind of want you to
what's the time sample got it out okay 117 go ahead okay so
because like all i can think of like it might be like a grotesque chili pepper but like it's
probably not that bad okay there are so many toys based off of you know the canine anatomy
yeah yeah uh-huh what would like the the color be like would it be like that orange or well for
a creepy uncle i imagine it would be like black like ebony black okay but for like but for like the
original it would be like chili pepper red i agree with that statement yep um
moving on moving on
uh polywag uh polywag going into my mouth nowadays
what are the movesets for polywag
it's a squirt so like is polywag just gonna squirt on me like i'm just i just kind of want to eat it
i could definitely see it being used as a plug but pound oh it uses pound
i'm like it probably knows like hypnosis pound hypnosis water gun okay you know what
i'll fuck it then eat it yeah also i'll smash and then you're gonna season it yourself and
then cook it exactly exactly you know i'd probably i'd probably just fuck it and let it live in a
pond backyard okay and then like call on it when you need to well yeah because he's gonna get stronger
and bigger yeah that's a good point so i might i might keep a couple some for eating and some for
other things might might maybe i'll farm them
the fuck a polywag farm
this is a brothel full of polywags okay what about poly world
oh what about poly world that's clearly a smash yeah like he looks like he could do like
some real good damage like some riona damage and then like some good aftercare yeah i feel like he
could like hypnotize you to make the pain go away but like you can still like look at the bruises
and be like oh this was nice you know yeah you know what yeah i like that because you know i'm a
i'm a riona girl myself so um and like however i'm not into fisting too much so i just i would just
ask he like i'd hope that you respect my boundaries for that you know yeah cool okay i'll
smash poly wrath you just gain some fingers and eyelids
and it looks like he's smiling with his little hypnosis beam in the middle yeah that's a good
point i kind of like the smug expression gloves off yeah he means business now gloves off
i'm gonna say smash i also say smash because like he's just a kitty pipe you put a little
hat on him that's a gentleman yeah um abra is a baby that's a child i'm not i don't want that i'm good
uh also did you know that abras are foxes what i thought they were like ant eaters
nah that's a fox oh weird yeah but like he's a weird looking fox yeah i'm not i'm not feeling
they're not too foxy i'm passing um cadabra okay he can get it you think i just don't like the
foo man shoe mustache just not my thing and like the i feel like that symbol on its tummy
reminds me of like some sort of ramen packaging he already has a spoon
yeah the tail i know yeah would it glow could i could i absolutely
um grandpa vibes yeah i'm not i'm not really a gilf
mind to close when he's about to bust oh so you always have a warning if you're just like
facing him
um i'm gonna say pass but you're gonna smash right yeah i'm gonna smash okay
alexam so like you lose the warning but he gets two spoons but like what is he doing with the
spoons he's putting them on your nips like a little like cold sort of play like instead of
ice cubes it's he's just cupping your little nippies with that yeah he's just he's just roaming on
them nips like you know a little a little fun a little fun during the intimacy he is also a psychic
type people are pointing out um he'll hand bone for your like an enjoyment and you can't do that
without a spoon and he's got two of them that's a smash i i'm gonna i'll sit in the cock chair
for that one because i just want to see how it goes down the cock to the cock dirt i go
oh
okay so obviously there's two for the nips there's one for the button there's one for each peek
boom can you like but like can you like pop one into your mouths you got something to suck on
oh yeah he can gag you with a spoon no problem
oh my god
the master of oh yeah he'd spoon you afterwards would you he be the big spoon a little spoon
i think with i think with all his spoons he's the master spoon
i think yeah i think i'd be relegated to the little spoon um i'm gonna
on alexia mega i might rob him because i like the gem of his spoons uh no i want actually you
know i'm stealing the spoons and the gem okay i'll smash you grab okay yeah smash the old smash
well he's distracted oh wait i mean but his spoons are gonna be in use okay i'll just i'll just
knock him on the head i'll just take him when he's when he's when he's done and he's he's like
sleeping like i'm okay that sounds good i think that's a good plan all right yeah my chop
that's a boy that's a shirtless child where's his parents somebody lost their sassy child
who's sassy child is this
it's like oh yeah nice to meet you it's like no can i get a fist bump can i can you can
me fist bump and i'm like can you fucking leave me off can i get a fist bump it's like you know like
bro fist like fist bump and i'm just like shut the fuck up you fucking try who let him in here
someone said shona kong
oh okay i passed okay thank god because it wasn't passed
that's that's a man
give me some of that give me some of that oh that's a good that's a good joke machoke me daddy
machoke me daddy that p is for pound town that's all i'm gonna say
you can tell look at that look at that bulge you know he's fucking packing it's either for
pound town or pussy bag and he's both because you know they ain't just using them for for like
moving boxes and pokemon that is some lonely housewise oh yeah 100 do you think he like can
take off the belt and like tie you with it too or like absolutely yeah thank you oh perfect okay
yeah smash for that whoa that's a lot of it that's a lot of it now he's just now he's just
showing off he's just showing off i just feel like i'll be fondled in all directions i'm
squirming in my chair uh yeah i mean that's a that's a smash that's a that's a smash 100%
um now now he's just showing off now he's the lava character from ben 10
i just feel like he would his hands would be hot and sweaty yeah i don't know like if it would
burn me or if like he could maintain the temperature a certain way so it could be like a warm
thing i don't know you know what he looks like he looks like the ad for anchor arms
from sponge bra you're right i can't now i'm a jerk yeah everybody loves me
he's forearm with heat blast arms yes that's what i mean i'm like he's a ben 10 character that's
literally him um i'm good oh he's 82 feet oh my god i mean he's gonna hug it you could you could
hug it and kind of straddle it a bit i guess yeah and like kind of like grind it like if you wanted
to do yeah if you wanted to do like a size play sort of thing oh well now i'm thinking about it
you know i'm thinking about it too do you want to like tag team that together maybe like we can
yeah yeah one on one on each side yeah we can maybe like oil ourselves up or what have you
yeah like a car wash yeah okay i'm yeah i'll do smash yeah like if i hadn't thought about it
then no it would have been a pass but i thought about it yeah rub up on his foot that's that's
what we're talking about no no you know you want to you come on bell sprout i mean look at that
that's that's like that's like i'm sorry like my favorite toy is a rose so i was just gifted
something similar to a rose recently and i have yes i saw that i you should definitely use that i
think you'll enjoy yourself um uh yeah i feel like it has uses for both genders
yeah he's definitely an accomplice in the bedroom yeah like say you have company over and you're
like you want to get you want to do something frisky freaky and they're like sure and instead of doing
like the grapefruit technique you just went out of bell sprout yeah i just like pull it out of the
side drawer and then and then it makes those noises like inappropriate popsicles noise yeah
inappropriate popsicle noises uh i like someone also pointed out that bell sprout is 69 so i i
thought that was funny too they knew what they were doing they knew what they were doing um i'm
gonna say yes i'm gonna smash bell sprout well i wouldn't be usually smashing i'm kind of just
like using it because i mean yeah the bell sprouts okay but what about weeping bell it gets a little
bit bigger again that's suction like i know the next one has teeth so i would say no but this one
i will say i would cover the eyes because i don't get some looking at me
you know it's not multiple you can have one for the top and for the titties
oh and just like put one on each tittie and then like have a third just be like yeah yeah i don't
care if it's spits acid it's going on my clitoris think of it as a chemical peel yeah it's like a
uh uh what is that like the vegesals like the badge
let's put that on there you know exfoliating i'm gonna smash victory bell however i'm good
um i don't want to climb inside i bet it would be really comfy yeah how big is a is a victory bell
i feel like they're about people's eyes james would often get eaten by his yeah okay that's a good point
he's probably got a stem inside that you could probably ride on maybe
i just feel like i feel like a guy would look at that and be like you know
i like a challenge because of those teeth on the edge
but then again you could use those to climb out if you're inside that's a good point we would have
to have a lot of communication in like boundary setting i feel like communication would be hard
if you're inside of its mouth like yeah i can't understand you yeah i'm gonna pass i'm gonna
pass uh tend to cool well i've seen enough hint i didn't know where this is going yeah we're i'm
smashing and grabbing um i've always wanted the gems off of this creature same i just like let me
just join those real quick but do you think they feel like tide pods like they're squishy gems
oh okay so it's either a stress toy like a fidget toy i literally have a fidget toy like right next
to me in my hands um or it's a you can it's yeah it has double usage you have two lovely little
tentacles and then you can squeeze it while it does its thing oh that's a smash yeah
you know i've never liked his face i feel like the beak could hold me in place like wrap around
my waist and then it would just like you know you see enough hentai to know what happened next
yeah so like does the beak close i don't know i feel like it would be able to like extend and like
yeah it's like kind of like i'm like making a like a little talking hand motion but nobody can
fucking see me no i get what you're doing you're doing like the middle finger and the thumb touching
like yeah exactly eggs literally i so i feel like he can do that freaky uh pokemon i don't know i feel
like he would pinch me i'm gonna pass on to you know i don't mind i'm i'm gonna take a i'll take
risks i'm gonna say i'll sit it i'll sit in the cocktail okay the cocktail okay um that's a rock
that's a rock it's not a boulder it's a rock it's a rock um i feel like i couldn't even grind on that
i feel like the hardest yeah i feel like the hardest would be too hard because you know how
there's like different levels for dildos um like the what you're gonna call it like silicone yeah
like the like the hardness of that like they're soft medium and hard i just feel like that would
just be very uncomfortable he's always hard that's a good point but if you if you if you went into
a rock tumbler for like three weeks and he came out smooth maybe maybe but as is no yeah a rock
that can just fist you and then like is he a grower is he a grower because like i don't know
where anything else is he's really just hands in the head i don't know if his mouth works so like
i don't i'm not feeling it i i just feel like he doesn't have a rock cock if you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah i know what you're saying um i don't care for the eyebrowed version either with
different fists and i don't like his hair yeah he's he's he's kind of ugly motherfucker um grabbler
yeah i don't know i i feel like it's a pass for grabbler yeah i feel like i would just get
dust and like sand and like dirt all in my crevices and i'm like i feel like he grit me well but
at the end of the day i feel like friction burn you know like he's definitely got a good hold of
you but like outside of that like what else what else yeah 100 um yeah they the same thing with
the other geodude one that was funny i don't know they just like yoink the fingers for the little
versions i'm passing on that um this is a lizard rock it's not even a good lizard rock yeah it looks
like they took like ikan's face and they kind of like smacked it on or like are really like
ikan in our box i don't fucking know just doesn't look right i don't like it it's kind of pissing
me off also he's just going like yeah and he just named golem like a golem's an actual thing
i'll be honest with you this is one of my least favorite pokemon in the any of the games
i don't like this pokemon because he's weird
i'm passing he's a weird little guy the alolan version is cute it's goofy he looks like he's
gonna sell me something like it gives me like um senchi from um dungeon meshi vibes and i think
it's adorable i wouldn't smash it though no also his tiny little baby on yes
what the fuck can you do with those those are like vestigial limbs
like a whale pass uh ponita
i'm good
smash you're gonna smash ponita
like ponies yeah ponies are cute i'll pass i will i'm gonna smash i'm gonna eat the the gellar
version or how the fuck you pronounce it i'm gonna smash that's a cotton candy tail right there
that i'm eating that's a that's a cute pony right there yeah it's very cute very cute pony
uh i'll i'll be i'll smash rapidash i won't lie to you i'll smash rapidash 100
percent yeah smash yeah oh it that is a handsome prince man oh my goodness
people like hello malady and like invite me to his castle oh yeah yeah i feel like
i'm just thinking of so many scenarios where he just treats me right like a princess
like he'll carry you yeah oh yeah although he's like although when i see him i kind of
think unicorn rules where they're only attracted to virgins oh that's a good point
but you know that's fine maybe he's different yeah maybe he doesn't judge maybe he doesn't judge
i can't relate because obviously i'm a virgin so
um of course madame of course um i'm a good christian girl um of course
slow poke alternate none outfit win i don't i want a non outfit so fucking bad
i want one so bad there's like one like one those little dress up ones on booth and i'm like
i need to snag that
confess i'm not gonna lie are you gonna smash slow poke is a smash and eat i'm just gonna eat
i'm not smashing but what tell me why explain well i just love slow poke because like you know
he's not gonna finish like the same time as you so you can get off as many times and then he'll have
like his delayed reaction and so he'll he'll last longer than like your typical pokemon because
he's always slow on the update yeah that's a good point that's a good point i think i'm going to
sit in the cuck dirt for them because i kind of want because because i kind of want to see how
you do it and then maybe you know because he takes forever i can like have my turn and then we can
consume him afterwards oh yeah season and then consume yeah like two little you know
spiders and then like we don't even have to eat the whole thing just the tail yeah because i heard
that the tail is a delicacy so i guess i'm gonna click on smash alongside you for that one
and of course it's like the same for this golden one i don't know this one looks a little bit sickly
to me i don't know i feel like he's got extra flavor extra flavor okay i'll let you have that one
i'm gonna pass yeah i'm gonna smash what about slow bro though he's on he's on two legs how am
i not smashing that i think i'm gonna pass because the spininess of the shell
i feel like it would get in the way i just feel like it would get in the way like like imagine
he like he turns around or like he just like accidentally bumps you with it like ow you know
like yeah he's watching i mean the shell's getting a free show at that point and i could care less
yeah you know i'm not obviously i don't care if i'm watched but um yeah i just i don't know
yeah i'm just i'm just gonna pass i'm gonna pass i gotta i gotta pass on the next one
he's just stuck he's just literally stuck i feel so bad i can't i can't help you bro
oh i can't help you bro i just want to get him out he looks so
oh chastity cage pokemon
chastity shell well i so because it's a chastity shell i can't smash but yes i guess i guess i
can consider him one of my good little boy sluts i'll i'll say
he would like that he would like to be a good yeah um
are you what about this one i don't know he's got smelly fingers
he looks like he kind of like don't know doesn't know how he got into this predicament
um like he like he just looks like he doesn't wash his hands yeah yeah i agree with this
i'm just gonna i'm gonna pass i'm gonna pass
uh magnumite uh smash smash does it vibrate like it's got to if you get like some other magnets
going yeah you can sit on the you can sit on the top screw with his knobs
you know i'll say yes i'll say yes just because i can play with his knobs
you can play with his knobs and i feel like little zapping would be cool so i'm gonna smash
yeah and then for magneton it's kind of the same thing you just have more pals to play with
you know that's the group activity yeah like that was the the this is the main course that was
the one before was the appetizer like you could play never have i ever with this one and whoever
had gets his app yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna smash and then like if you undo the screws you can have
like three of them yeah did you want to do you want to tag team on that one with me
sure i'll tag yeah i feel like that would just be a really fun time just like a couple of
friends hanging out we can have some drinks and you know play a couple of games like like you said
i'd be fun i like that casual pokemon get together exactly um so i know this one's a bird
but he's a very handsome bird uh he came and brought his own vegetable i'm cooking him
i'm i'm smashing him okay i'm eating him if you want to season him for me that's fine
yeah i don't want to season it for you okay yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna eat it however
the next one has a certain je ne sais quoi and that's fresh yeah like i don't know why but i'm
getting like berserk vibes like you've got guts yeah he's like the big big sword you know that
express i don't i want to i think i might smash like he looks at you over his shoulders like
stand back stand back or i guess he wouldn't call you a kitten he'd probably say
stand back duckling yeah that's cute that's actually cute as hell if he called me as duckling
i'm gonna yeah i'm smashing this one um i don't even want to eat that
uh that's a pass for me yeah it's a pass because he looks dusty yeah yeah
like scratchy feeling like it's not like feathers it's like scratchy fur or like a mixture of like
hair like um like a like really itchy hey uh sama dodrio yeah also they fight all the time
i was yeah i was gonna say i'm like i feel like they would just argue about like what to do next
and i'm not in the mood for that yeah yeah like i would hang out with that third head but that's
not yeah like have a chat with them just be like forget the other guys like let's just hang out
just pretend it's us it's a seal this is a seal i can't tell if i want to eat it or not but so
because of that i'll spare it i'm gonna spare it as well because like i know seals always get a
bad rap especially since i have this have they stopped the clubbings oh my gosh i think they
i think they did like crack down on that like clubbing baby seals good i'm gonna spare him yeah
i don't want to eat or smash him same um dugong is so cute
but i feel like maneuvering in the bedroom would be difficult she's a lady
i don't i just want to take her out you know like we're a good time take her dancing yeah
like are we gonna go in the water yeah like secret nice swimming like take her to a local pool
want to be like a dolphin moment if it was a male do okay not like that type of dolphin moment
i fucking hate dolphins they are pretty shitty they're really shitty creatures they're smart but
that's what makes them shitty is that they know what they do yeah i'm gonna say pass i'd probably
just take her out yeah and then become like friends like if i were a guy with the equipment it
probably be a oh hundred percent like there's a lot of the ones like i remember um didn't you like
with with the other uh the other girl that you did this with um that one weird cat uh didn't you
guys also do like a penis envy version as well oh right right right yeah penis envy one yeah i think
we should also like sneak that in so i'll say like i i definitely have penis envy for this one if i
was a dude i'd take my skull you know as a madame i'll take my strap and you know i guess then that
means i smash because i can just use a strap okay um grimer you know i feel like he could get into
crevices ew but like doesn't he like poison type like i just feel like i'd never stopped me before
i don't want i don't want a uti man my cats are like running crazy around my house right now um
i think they're also agitated yeah gross and stinky i'm i don't know where he's been what
if he gives me something yeah like what i don't need that i don't need i don't need you know the
the clap you know good can you get the clap from a pokemon you know i'm gonna pass only because
he's in the sewer if he's in crevices i don't know where he's been he probably has carrying everything
i mean it's it's okay i live in a junkyard so it's fine yeah but you like you dress up and
you make yourself nice and you clean yourself from time to time this guy wallowing and filth
yeah i guess you're right same with this a lowland version that just looks like hey
i would be friends with him i would be friends he has such a he has such a nice smile yeah really
cute nice smile um you know i'd i'd kind of like give him hints here and there that he smells bad
like as a friend be like hey did you like no no no just take him to a magic the gathering like
oh then you blend right in yeah yeah good point you wouldn't you wouldn't even notice yeah
uh muck
same same deal i guess yeah muck looks like he would call me bad names with that expression
like that gesture it's just like really aggressive but muck spelled backwards is a good point maybe
maybe my uh if i was a dude i'd like give it a shot because i feel like i mean everybody knows
i'm into slime girls and he's kind of slimy so yeah but he's still like the same as grimer yeah
i'm gonna pass i will also pass this one just looks like this one's got a shit in it i just
want to eat this one like i i'm just canonically on my head canon is that this is frozen yogurt
or like some sort of soft serve i feel like i feel like he's just been crawling on the ground
and you might get food poisoning maybe i'd probably eat it and then just feel bad afterwards
i'm gonna pass pass uh oh that's a smash that's a smash what that tongue do baby girl
um
yeah smash um if i was a dude cloister if i'm i'm a lady smash you're gonna you're gonna
smash cloister as a lady yeah you could you could like actually oh my god you're right there's so
many different like little nodules on the yeah you know what i was a little bit worried about
like its little pointer part but i'm going to risk it for the biscuit it'll poke your
butt it'll poke it'll poke your butt in a little bit yeah but like it probably still has the same
tongue as the shelter did exactly and then like someone mentioned like look at those plugs a hundred
percent yeah i'm smash it's it's for sharing castley
uh i'm gonna say pass only because it's just a ball yeah an incorp. incorp. incorp. incoriable ball
i can't pronounce that either either somebody's gonna try a corioball there we go got it
I kind of want to pop it in my mouth like a great, but it's a ghost, so it's not
tangible, so
I'll pass
Happens to the best of us. It's like when we had one one too many drinks, you know
You wake up somebody didn't expect
Just ghastly
He's like, did you like it as much as I did
Um
Yeah, Hunter
Smash yeah, he's got hands and he got a tongue
That's true. He do got that tongue. I'm gonna smash as well
Like I don't even worry. I'm not even worried about his ghost equipment. He's got like three out of
Three out of four. Yeah
Yeah, that's a little bagged smash. That's a Gengar. Yeah, that's a Gengar
Come on
Did you want to get to a hundred and then wind down it's like a little bit chatting. Yeah, cool. Okay, so smash Gengar
What the fuck is this
Gengar mega
They look like punches
Yeah, I can't really tell what's going on here, I'm gonna pass
I'm confused. I love the expression like, you know, I feel like we'd have crazy wild
You know smashing this but I just yeah, I'm a little bit confused. So I'm gonna pass
He's rolling out the red carpet for you baby girl
Literally, do you I feel like how big is Gengar Gigantamax? Because I feel like each one of us can take each side of that tongue
And we can do the same thing that we would do for the Gigantamax
My champ
Yeah, I think I think so. That's a smash. Yeah. Yeah. He's a haunted carnival, right? You're correct
Where are we are smashing?
Yes, we are smashing this this carnival, right? Mm-hmm
That's a rock
This is a collective group of rocks like I want to smash this like really bad, but again Onyx is giant
and
Like I couldn't use him for like
plugging stuff
No, this is like a group effort. You'd have to get like a whole party to try to contact
Yeah, exactly. So I'm gonna pass just for my own safety
It's drowsy. It's every hypno-comics
I feel like yeah, I feel like he would just make me do the most depraved shit
But not even like the fun stuff like look how like, you know, see his bottom half
You know, he's into some chocolate play
Oh
So he's got that weird elephant. No, yeah, like you just know he's gonna be like hey
That's just feel good. He's just all snuffling for truffles up in you. Yeah, I just
It's gross like ugly ugly bastard and like but this isn't like a good ugly bastard, you know, there's good
So I'm gonna I'm good. Yeah pass. It's not like Venus or yeah
Yeah, I would prefer Venus or over him
Hypno again, however that knows
I'm I'm looking at that nose and you know
But I was gonna say one of my favorite songs the Humpty dance from digital underground
One of the lines is in a 69. My Humpty nose will tickle your rear and
I
Kind of like that
So any is five fingers
Our 34 artists a sample are you smashing?
Are you gonna sit in the dirt for that one
No, I I'm really torn
I just feel like I'd like him better if he took a nap first because he just looks tired
Yeah, do you think he wouldn't like try as hard?
Yeah, I don't think he would try as hard because he knows he could just put you under like hypnosis
Oh, you're like a really lazy lover. That's true. And then he could be like, oh, yeah
We totally did stuff and he'd be like, oh, I really and then you like actually nothing happens. It's just really just yeah
Like he puts you down he made it he gave you the suggestion
Oh, you felt really good during our time together and he's just sitting there reading the newspaper. Yeah. Yeah, just like
Just like writing on the belly
Nothing
And then he brings you up and he's like was it good for you?
I think I'm okay that like I think I've been convinced I don't think I want hip-no anymore
Oh, yeah, I don't yeah, I'm a pass I'm eating this crab
You know what I'll watch you boil this crab. Okay. Yeah, I'll eat it. I'll have a little little
crab boil
Have some people over
That claw meat looks delicious
I'll make you something. Thank you. I'll I'll serve you some of that slow poke tail that you like. Oh, yeah
Nice and rare. Yeah, I think we have a you can make a make a dinner date out of that one. Mm-hmm
Yeah, a real crabby boil. Yeah, same with Kingler same thing
What
Like a bubble beard
Because it looks like it's like king crab legs a hundred percent my favorite
um
Smash smash. I'm so happy we ended we're ending on this one
Like how could you not how could you not smash?
Both are like so multi-purpose
Like you can write them you can
That's it
No, I think you could make
No, wait, how big is Voltorb because I'm like, could I pop them in? I don't think so
I don't like maybe a baby one if he was small
Yeah, maybe a smaller one and then I could use it use it as a like a little a little
You know
It doesn't that doesn't split apart. It doesn't have a mouth. The other one has a mouth
Yeah, the other one has the teeth. Yeah
Hmm
Aren't they the size of a pokeball? Well, it's going up my at no
Um all pokemon can shrink oh that make yeah that make can they wait
Well if they go inside the pokeball tree, yeah
So like well like I guess what do they do they ever show what the incentive of pokeball looks like? I can't remember
Um, well, it's like suspended animation, isn't it?
I like to think that it's a little environment. Yeah, I always like the picture. It's like they have like a whole ass house in there
I'd like to sit in a pokeball. I bet it'd be really comfy
Yeah, it's um the same thing as floor time. Do you think that like tomas tummy is like a like like a pokeball?
Oh, absolutely. Yeah, she can she can go in there herself. So that's pretty cool
I always I always wondered about that. I feel like I would love to hang out in a tomas tomas little
Um
poor text tummy thing
It's a little hangout spot in there. Yeah, you have fun. Yeah, um
Okay, I think well, I think we'll end it on voltorb. I'll I'll I'll say smash on voltorb
Um, let's let's chat with
Chat with a harem
In some of your fans the paparazzi is here
Um
Do electrode electrode is like the same thing. Oh, what the fuck is this thing pass on the wooden version? I'm good. Um
And then smash on electrode. Yeah
Yeah, he's got a cocky expression and I like it on his wooden version. All right. We're leaving off on eggs
Yeah
I'm just eating those. Okay. I mean you can't talk about this anywhere. Um, you need jesus. It was great great stream
This is the most well-smashed pass I've seen yet
Um
From the other perspective, that's true as a as a girl
Yeah, because I think like yeah markiplier has done like the most like famous one
Like the one has like so many views or whatever
Um, he's he's a dude. So it's a different perspective for us. Us girly pops out here
Yeah
She is great. She is she is an absolute doll. I love her to death
such a bestie
You're you're the best
Um
Okay, is there any like questions you want to ask trinket before she goes don't forget by the way
her information
is um
In my description another thing is that uh, she does bunk with tomah from time to time. So it is under tomah's name
Yes
That is why i'm your step dog or your dog-in-law just depending on how you feel about me. Exactly. Yeah
You get to make that choice. She gives you she gives you that opportunity
If she pops the eggs and does she then become the east
Oh, yes, I do stream on twitch. I'm I'm quite the gamer. She's a ultimate gamer and she's a great artist
Or as tomah the artist
You both are very talented
Tomah draws. I act. Yeah, that's true. That's true. Um
Yeah, she streams on twitch
Uh, let me see
If anybody don't know
Oh, we were chatting up
Step dog, please bark
Okay, okay, it was just it was just one person
Thank you for the the super charlie. Appreciate it. Thank you guys and thank you for all the members. So sweet. So nice
So kind to us. Um
Step dog, please bark
That's up to you if you want to do that
Okay
That was so cute. Oh my god, I would I would totally give you the best walkies for that
I mean, that's that's cool
Yeah, just just you know something casual, you know casual walkies
um
And then I guess I have to take my people out my my hair. I'm out on walkies sometimes since they've been influenced by your walkies
But I know fair. We don't get walkies
but yeah
Oh, what's your favorite smash that you didn't get to cover this dream?
Well, who's well, you'll have to find out the next time. You don't think we're gonna continue this. Yeah, we are
We're gonna do all of them
All 1,123 fuck. All right. Wait, is that that many? I thought there was like 800
I mean the number is like right there. Oh Jesus Christ. Um, yeah, we'll figure that out
to be continued
Gonna smash em all and then we can
if if we
We can do like the miltank versions. There's like a whole miltank smasher pass of like miltank fusions
Oh
That one sounds delightful. They're they're a little cursed, but I think that one
Actually, I might have to like
have sensors
Um
Okay, well
It has been lovely everybody. I'm gonna end stream here
How about good wonderful night? Please check out trinket and tomah
um
And I'll see you guys around sweet dreams of all the pokemon scenarios that you heard me
drink it talk about
Have a good night here
Bye
You